it's been a particularly difficult er
for Nigerians who's all dependent
economy is struggling low prices and
cuts in production resulted in huge
losses of revenue but more worrying for
Africa's biggest producer is the damage
the current glut will do with few
storage facilities the options for
Nigeria like many small and medium sized
producers is to give our it's oil or
shut down some wells what do i fastened
today is an unprecedented blood nobody
has ever seen taking 2 billion barrels
into storage within tools does never
happen what it means I've long when
countries come back to work
there'll be so much supply that the
demand cannot compensate for that
revenue shortfalls from all have already
forced the Nigerian government to
consider an almost 40 percent cut in
this year spending estimates nearly
doubles alternative for companies that
you've had to shut down can I bring back
us if I can bring back us what happens
next so you are better off pain of
somebody to take the clip of it but
that's not a permanent situation the
current cost of producing a barrel of
oil in Nigeria is about the same as the
market price something produces an
expert say isn't sustainable for a long
period Nigeria's oil company then MPC
says it's engaging its joint venture
partners the oil companies to see how
they will father cut production the
country's current output is 1.4 million
barrels of oil a day and as producers
desperately look to show of prices it's
also possible that Nigeria will be
forced to make further cuts experts warn
that the current instability in the oil
market is set to further damaged the
economy Nigeria imports a significant
amount of consumer goods including
refined petroleum product the ability to
form the foreign exchange market will
also be limited and that will
automatically translate into the
vibration of other international aid
compatible currencies and that will
automatically transmit into higher in
prices for important books and that will
significantly reduce the standard of
living of an average material
a bleak focused that could even get
worse if the current market shock
continues for a long time muhammad idris
al jazeera Abuja